if you're looking for ways to seize your
opportunity have an I don't care
attitude and have fun while working then
this video is for you
if you don't value your own life that's
taking it to an extreme people tend to
respect or being afraid of that person
once I got my break I didn't I was 44 at
the time which is probably good because
I would have really made a mess of it if
it had happened to me earlier everybody
should be pushing it and having a good
day at work need motivation watch a top
10 with belief nation what's up it's
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out into the world so let's
take your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew on today's lessons from a man who
fell in love with food while in his
youth on a family vacation in France and
he tried his first oyster to now
becoming a TV personality and one of the
most popular chefs in the world
he's Anthony Bourdain and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success enjoy
alright let's get this started rule
number one is having I don't care
attitude
I moved from 44 year old for high cook
basically to whatever the hell it is I
do now pretty much overnight on the
basis of a memoir where I pretty much
fest up to everything so there's really
I'm an open book
I don't have and I've never had a
reputation to lose which is a huge
advantage I mean it's an enormous Lee
liberating thing when everybody knows
all the nasty about you already nobody
heard you you you're free to say what
you want and have an opinion it's like
oh yeah we used to be a junkie yeah what
else I've done many bad things in my
life many awful awful things that I'm
not proud of but but uh you know I'm not
pretending to be I think it's a matter
of the age as well you know I joke about
you know not giving up being a very good
business model for me but it's true the
absolute certainty that no one was ever
going to care about or buy or read
Kitchen Confidential was what allowed me
to write it I didn't have to think about
what people expected I didn't care and
as a result I was able to write this
book quickly and without a lot without
tormenting myself and that seemed to
work out and I learned from that
experience that I tried very hard to
whether meeting with a group of
television executives or telling a story
I I don't think about the fans I don't
think about what audiences expect and
I'm not afraid of what will they think
of me or what if I what if what if they
don't like it and I'm not on television
anymore and I found that works I mean if
you don't value your own life that's
taking it to an extreme people tend to
respect or for being afraid of that
person you know the person in a bar
fight who clearly has no concern for
their own personal health or welfare is
a dangerous person and
particularly in television what people
the television industry the
entertainment industry in general the
thing that everybody the great unifying
factor of television is that everyone
who is on television is desperate to
stay on television no matter what you
know anyone who's ever been on Top Chef
you know it's like what happens when
it's over you know so when you're the
rare person walks into a room and some
television executive it really don't
care you know I'll go back to brunch I
don't care this is a very interesting
one to start off on and I think really
the messages comes down to authenticity
it's understanding who you are and then
being who you are in every situation and
if people can't handle it then it's
probably not better for you to be in
that situation in the first place it
applies to your business if you are
working with customers who are not
aligned with your values who are
expecting you to act a certain way and
you don't want to act that way and it's
a fake version of you you're never gonna
have long-term success with them and
it's better to part ways early and to
recognize that as soon as possible and
be able to move on and it's your
customers your employees your suppliers
your partners maybe a contact anybody
who doesn't get your vibe that's okay
but you have to stay true to you if you
want to have ultimate success it's a
good one to lead off on Thank You
Anthony now it's time for number two do
things differently whatever we did last
week no matter how well it was received
how successful it was how the ratings
were how much people loved it whatever
we're gonna do next week we want to try
really really hard to undermine
completely what we did last week or to
present a moving target we don't want
ever for the network to be able to say I
think I figured out what the hell it is
that you guys are doing let's do more of
that because by the time they figure
that out we will moved on to something
else so we spent a lot of time sitting
around having a few cocktails thinking
what is the most nothing we can do
and I don't know which one of you guys
said let's do a food show all in black
and white yeah
that's how good we are we can make food
porn in black and white and when we
started talking about then we started
talking about early neo-realist Italian
films that you know one percent of our
audience might have seen and we went out
and did just about the stupidest thing
you could do on you know and in a travel
and food we made it all black and white
show live we never like we live and they
said no way they said that was it is our
it is for me it's my money when
Robbinsville my proudest moment because
it was just so stupid
and and it looks so beautiful and a work
you guys did and that that the indie
editing and the the music everything
everybody everything worked exactly
better than we could have imagined it
all came together I think this ties in
really well to the last point about
being authentic because if you are
always authentic to you then you are
always changing and evolving as human
being therefore your business needs to
constantly be evolving and changing
alongside you when you get bored is when
you have evolved as a person but your
business hasn't evolved alongside you
and that's when people get tired of the
companies and they want to move on and
they want to turn into passive income
they want to do something else your
business needs to be a constant
reflection of who you are
let's go to rule number three always be
prepared
there have been so many Titanic
screw-ups in my life and it's the story
and how I learned to cook I wrote about
is how I learned to kind of not cook on
television you know if you've ever
there's a whole different form of
cooking it's an it's not cooking that
it's a freakish you know form of Kabuki
involving
involving knives and hot liquids and and
you know you learn that you know when
you're doing a you know first of all
these segments it's three minutes long
and generally you know if these News
Studios at 7 o'clock in the morning you
know that those happy peppy news shows
so they're you know it crusted with
daisies and freakishly adorned made-up
people with fluffy hair so they're
drinking that coffee no no doubt they've
told you beforehand that although our
kitchens really well equipped it's like
a little Suzy homemaker dollhouse
you know we're got a hot plate food and
crusted it stinks our chef of course is
you know we're happy to help you some
local burnout from the golf club
we can get you any food you want you
know you know if they have it you know
at the supermarket or the kwik-e-mart at
the corner
what's arugula you know can you use
iceberg instead no our hosts are really
adventurous eaters you know which
apparently means they like mayonnaise
with their curly fries so when you show
up for a few of these you start to get
real smart about what you got to do
because it's really not about the food
it's I want to look cool for three
minutes while I'm Hawking the book and I
don't want to cut myself or anyone else
or you know spill hot oil on my genitals
so what will you do that instead of a
father being an artichoke fried salad
you would do you try to do something
like steaming mussels it's really good
because you could do that in three
minutes I've learned that so I've been
banging that gong for a long time I'm
mussels perfect you know you'll learn to
find safe quick food that you know and
when it's done it looks like this you
know you learn to bring your own you you
learn as in just as in cooking anywhere
else when you're not in your comfort
zone
assume the worst absolutely assume the
worst and be prepared for it so I love
this point because Carmichael my last
name is a Scottish clan and our slogan
that's the family slogan is to yield
pray I don't know why it's French
but that means always ready always be
ready and so Carmichael's are always
ready and so I just love that point I
love that we were able to include that
in this Anthony Bourdain video but I
agree you gotta always be ready you
gotta always be prepared the more you
know your stuff the easier time you're
gonna have time for rule number four
have fun working making TV should be fun
it should be a creative expression it
should be fun for me it should be
interesting for me and it should be fun
and interesting for the people who
really talented creative people I work
with and that means the shooters the
editors the producers the sound mixers
the colorist everybody should be pushing
it and having a good day at work when
they come to work on this show otherwise
there's really no point there are many
many more dignified things in this world
to do than make television you should
have fun when you do it I'm really
curious how many people go to business
with their own company trying to optima
for fun like do you optimize your fun do
you try to do the work that you find fun
you know I love doing these videos it's
a lot of work I'm making a hundred plus
videos just today but I love doing it
doesn't seem like work because I'm doing
the work that I love and you wanna one
find work that you loved you can have
fun doing and to bring on people who
love doing their job so that nobody is a
downer and everybody's bringing their
best and having fun every day I love it
time for rule number five find your
dream so any advice for somebody looking
to find what they love short answer on
cooking is before you spend money on
cooking school go and work in a
restaurant even for free if necessary
work in a busy restaurant and you know
give yourself enough time to understand
how hard it is how little money will be
making how long it will take you to pay
back that student loan how just how
difficult and unglamorous it is and at
how insane you have to be to to find a
home and if you know there are two types
of people people who love the restaurant
business and thrive on that sort of
insanity and adrenaline and futility and
an inequity that sounds great pressure
in the heat and then there are normal
people and you need to find out before
you go to school so I'm all for pursuing
your dream but but I think it's a good
idea to go find out really you know
before you invest in that dream either
time or money you know find out what
that means you know if there's a
downside you know I don't know how we
all got this gig you know I think was
yeah I mean I you know are you pursuing
your dream
yeah me too I left into that clip and
the advice is great it's it's the advice
I give to like go get a job to learn the
industry and see if this is for you
because often the grass is greener on
the other side you have perceptions of
how you think an industry is gonna be
not just cook in any industry go work
for somebody who has ten employees or
less who you want to be like you want to
have that kind of business in a couple
of years and go work for them and see
and see do you want that lifestyle do
you want to be like them do you enjoy
the way that they're living and if yes
then continue on with no maybe you want
to go do something else and it's a great
advise to go work for that person first
before spending the money spending the
time going down the wrong path time for
rule number six love the process I like
making things I'm a guy who should have
a project I I mean II when I was a chef
I was clearly somebody who liked
multitasking but I think I like making
things whether it's a TV show a story a
plate of food I don't really even need
to have it afterwards that the the
process I think being a chef cooking
conditions you to the tiny technical
satisfactions of properly executing a
single plate having a kind of a private
moment when that plate sits there
momentarily in the window before it goes
out it in the dining room to be ruined
where you look at it and you know you
did is you did this particular thing
well it's a very private moment I think
that's been useful in being learning to
like something so temporary so fleeting
I think that's Bennie's full in and
being happy and television and and and
writing I I you know I like the process
of the editing process the
pre-production process that the nuts and
bolts that they get the technical
satisfaction of putting these pieces and
elements together in conjunction with
other people and having a one tiny
golden moment where you you say that
pretty good I really love this point I
don't know if you guys caught that
little moment where he said he enjoys it
even if he doesn't get to eat the food
or see the result right he just enjoys
the process and that ties in really well
with rule number four of have fun
working you got to enjoy the process and
not the result it's not just shooting
for 10 million subscribers or million
subscribers or whatever your your end
result goal is you have to enjoy the
work on the way to achieving that goal
or it's never gonna happen
I love making YouTube videos and that's
why I'm having success you better love
what you're doing if you want to have
success and not just say I'm gonna do
whatever it takes because if you don't
love doing most of that work of whatever
it takes you're just not gonna do it
time for rule number seven find your
creative process show up every day and
just do it don't weed your own stuff
until you have a pile of it you know I
think if you head it yourself every day
if you're constantly rewriting reading
and revising don't do that
you know Whaley have 100 pages then if
you lose 75 of them you know you'll
still get you still get 25 you still
feel like a writer instead of you know
hating yourself and thinking it's all
futile writing for me is a
problem-solving exercise yeah okay if
you have a good writing day in the
morning I write the morning I wake up
and before I have any time to think
about all the million and one reasons to
not write I start writing and I write as
much as I can and I go go go go go and
then I shove it in the door and I don't
look at it for a long time I'm always
excited to see different people's create
a process to see how I might be able to
apply something of that into the way
that I work at the end of the day you've
got to find the thing that works for you
whether it's working in the morning
working at night working over lunch
involving other people being so low
spending huge chunks of time or little
little blocks of time overtime there's
no right answer but there's one right
answer for you and you have to
experiment so you can find it let's go
to rule number eight invest emotionally
look at all the other shows like to try
to be like us they suck
it's the real scenes we're all sitting
there like like like mummies welcome to
my home guy you know please enjoy our
food you know that the photography is
ugly there the lighting if any seems
spectacularly inept there's no human
dimension it's all happy horse
everything's great
please help me understand why are we so
damn Goods accent bummy we got a heart
man yeah we got heart I think that's you
me these guys post people editors I mean
everybody involves got heart and we're
trying to do something good you know
hard explains why
III think why particularly you know
Emile scenes with people seem to work a
little bit better you know i I've often
said you know we that we take the time
we drink with people you know that how
cool you know that we're not alcoholics
that we're we're television
professionals drinking with our subjects
and the people who host us on the show
it certainly helps but I think it's a
it's it's a function of so we spend the
time with the people we're not just gang
rushing some poor rice farmer well you
know and and saying okay you know the
scenes starting now you know you're you
know get totally out of the trailer I go
and I sit down I take a couple of bites
you know boom good back to the trailer I
talk about time but then again this is a
you know this is a handcrafted outfit
you know this is this is you know we're
not target you know we're we're Hermes
okay where it takes a long damn time to
make the bag but at the end of the day
okay it's expensive it's a damn nice bag
so you can see the amount of love that
he brings in multiple clips now how much
care he has how much he disregards what
other people think about him and he'll
just always go in on listen to his heart
and that's where you went and you guys
have to do the same thing you wanna win
you gotta listen to your heart you got
to do the things you're passionate about
and you have to
time for rule number nine seize
opportunity well I was quite sure when I
wrote Kitchen Confidential that no one
was gonna read it it was both the that
was a very liberating thing because I'd
never had to think I didn't have the
burden of trying to imagine what people
would expect or what they might like or
dislike or what the market wanted I
didn't think of it I wasn't thinking
about any of those things I had or not
because of this little article I had an
opportunity to tell a story and I wanted
it to be entertaining and legit for
people in my industry in the New York
area but this was this far as I thought
it was gonna go and even after TV people
started offering these shows I very much
thought I'd better keep my day job this
can't possibly work out yeah TV who who
gets to have fun on TV yeah you know who
gets to make a living writing I mean
I've been in the restaurant business a
long time the restaurant business is of
course filled with people who think that
some day they're gonna make a living
writing or acting or in entertainment
somehow and I knew this was delusional
behavior you know from 30 years of
seeing it up close so look it was a big
everything changed
I really think the only thing you can
credit me for is that I didn't [ __ ] it
all up and once I got my break I didn't
I was 44 at the time which is probably
good because I would have really made a
mess of it if it had happened to me
earlier you know I recognized that it
was late in life yeah I caught a big
break here let's not you know let's not
do make the usual mistakes what I find
really interesting in this clip is when
he was older when it happened to he was
already a little cynical that everybody
wanted to do it it's not realistic it's
never gonna happen
don't get your hopes up and bark up that
tree because it's probably not gonna
happen and yet he was still open to the
concept when it did happen he was still
open to the idea of that being a
potential path for him even though he
was older and he assumed it wasn't gonna
work out I find that I find that
interesting you know sit on that one for
a while I'm gonna sit on that where I
move it to the next rule number
ten keep it simple I'm old-school I
believe that a scrambled egg or an
omelet for that matter is principally
about the egg so I use a hot pan not too
terribly hot but hot I crack my eggs on
a flat surface put them into an
intermediate vessel like a little cup
work and make sure there's no shells
involved so no shells get into the
actual mix I beat them being careful not
to over beat them with the fork you do
want to sort of have a ripple of white
and yellow throughout you just don't
want to make it a complete sort of
homogeneous yellow always fresh also
very important you want a good fresh egg
then you want to do this meaning you
want to beat your egg just prior to
putting them in the pan you don't want
to do that ahead of time and let it sit
that you get this sort of odd graying
stippling effect that's you probably
recognize some greasy spoons you don't
want that salt and pepper I don't add
water I don't add cream I just don't
feel that uh that milk or cream adds
anything again it's about the egg you
know you're not making a quiche here you
make a scrambled eggs I moved them into
the into the pan into a preheated hot
pan with plenty of foaming cold butter
and then I let them form up a little bit
and then push them around using sort of
a figure 8 pattern to I don't know
whether you'd say sort of fold you know
you don't want tiny little bits of egg
as your final product you want something
fluffy Airy rippled with a nice textural
note where you taste the egg very very
simple dish but like a lot of really
good simple things more often than not
people find a way to over complicate
them and screw them up I've never had to
think so much about what goes into a
scrambled egg ever and that just shows
why Anthony Bourdain is the man
you
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I would say rule number
three always be prepared as my personal
favorite because that's the comical
slogan I gotta go with I gotta go with
team karmic all I want to know from you
guys though what was your favorite rule
are you with me are you with team
Carmichael always be prepared rule
number three is your favorite or was
there another one that had a bigger
impact on you leaving the comments below
let me know now I made this video
because cloud Deena Madrid asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next check out
the link in the description for the
request line and you can go and cast
your vote I also want to give a quick
shout out to Marta Magdalena thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting the review on
your Instagram page I really appreciate
the support and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
well what do we add what do I hate most
what do we hate most of the ship the
walk-in and the goodbye back way back
when we would do it was called the
walk-in where it's like okay Tony stand
outside the house and this is to see
where you walk in and you meet your
hosts and in worst case scenario be okay
well we kind of would like to do that
again boy
you it's impossible to feel any more of
an [ __ ] than you know warmly
introduce yourself to somebody and then
I'll be right back to do it again only
thing worse is to thank you so much for
the meal and letting me in your home
goodbye and then you got to go back and
do that again so we we just don't we
don't do it I mean where the whole
organism is created to never have that
kind of artificiality I I mean I have a
point of view and I'm very aware of the
fact that making television is a
manipulative process you know I wanted
people there's no question about it I
wanted people to feel a certain way
watching these shows I could have given
this guy a much more friendly cut if I
wanted to so you know I want people to
feel for years I wanted people to feel
hungry when they saw the food I'm eating
or you know the way you lay in music and
what you cut away to these are it's a
very manipulative process so I and I
enjoy that process it's its storytelling
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people
passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten gross a
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
Clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details